I was very pleased to hear broad support
for the circular economy action plan
amongst the minister's greening our
economy is already happening today and
it's happening in our society there is
no choice anymore there's no alternative
if we want to create sustainable
economies for the future if we want to
be competitive globally and if we want
growth and jobs without exhausting our
resources as government authorities we
need to set the right incentives and the
action plan will contribute to that the
value of the action plan lies in
addressing all phases of the life cycle
of products for a European circular
economy independent studies have
identified some savings of around 600
billion euros for EU businesses which is
equivalent to around eight percent of
the total and will turn over this would
mean the creation of around five hundred
and eighty thousand jobs and a reduction
of EU carbon emissions by some 450
million tons each and every year from
the transition to the circular economy
on the implementation of the seventh
environmental action plan which was also
discussed we acknowledged that the task
of implementing the seventh EAP is also
a joint responsibility joint
responsibility between decommission and
d member states I have confirmed today
to the Energy Council that the
Commission has a firm intention to
comply with the judgment of the court
and will present before the summer
scientific criteria to identify
endocrine disruptors based on the WHL
definition the decision to finally the
almost completely impact assessment has
been questioned by some ministers in the
letters addressed to Commission novella
and myself also
better we would like to make full use of
the information for the gathered from
difference scientific studies and from
now almost finalized impact assessment